bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de ski mag le 23 juillet prochain
débuteront les jo de tokyo mais à saint
quentin en yvelines
on prépare déjà les jumeaux 2024 puisque
cinq épreuves se tiendront sur le
territoire les différents sites sont en
cours d'aménagement ou d'ajustement
les retombées économiques médiatiques
l'affluence sur l'agglomération et la
région rien n'est laissé au hasard
les géo 2024 on en parle c'est parti
[Musique]
on est content que les géo et arrive en
2024 des fils pour lui la 51 12
je pense que ça va rassembler les gens
et que c'est ce qui manque depuis
l'histoire du coït en fait je sais tout
ah ben je pense que c'est bon pour pour
l'animation pour s'armer du monde et des
touristes les échanges
les gens vont se rassembler vont
partager des moments comme ça avec des
amis ça mais la visibilité encore un peu
plus sur la paris et puis les gens
vivant dans les environs de paris par
exemple 50 ans ça peut relancer
l'économie fonctionne très bien que
c'est dire en france et en particulier à
51 puisque on a tous là on va avoir
beaucoup de choses sur place
un bel événement pour pour nous vu que
c'est pas loin de chez nous ça et que ça
peut être sympa de voir une course de
vélo au vélodrome alors avançons
ensemble déjà impliqué
[Musique]
on
on a déjà des réunions de façon
régulière avec paris 2024 pour pour
travailler sur la partie on va dire
belle anticipation de l'événement le
public l'accueil du public tout ce qui
va être hospitality tout ce qui va être
un
préparation du parcours donc donc par
rapport à ça on est déjà en ai gr dedans
c'est comme un bonheur pour nous ça va
faire resplendir le territoire rayonner
la france est quelque part on a mis
notre petite pierre à l'édifice pour
construire ce projet olympique alors no
stress pour saint quentin en yvelines de
recevoir des grands événements parce que
c'est notre adn c'est notre essence
[Musique]
ensuite on est dans un lieu qu'on a
bâtie tous les uns les autres de manière
magnifique est prévu pour cela en 2024
le territoire saint quentinois
accueillera cinq épreuves olympiques
dont une paralympiques
à commencer par les épreuves de golf au
golf national de guyancourt à l'endroit
même où s'était déroulé la ryder cup dès
on sait que le site est prêt pour
accueillir des événements de grande
ampleur une ryder cup c'était quand même
deux cent soixante dix mille personnes
sur une semaine ce qui vont monstrueux
dans les faits d'énormes travaux avant
avant la ryder cup on avait fermé le
site pendant pratiquement un an pendant
dix mois on a fait beaucoup de travaux
de drainage
beaucoup de travaux on à reconfigurer
également quelques quelques trous on a
fait un petit peu de changements de
design du parcours aujourd'hui le golf
national ça juste pour les jo à venir
pour l'événement donc tout est prêt on
sait ce qu'on a on sait qu'on est équipé
en fibre toute la partie logistique on
sait où il faudra mettre les choses mais
après globalement je pense que c'est un
événement qui sera différente je pense
que paris 2024 aura envie de mettre sa
patte et par rapport à ça et nous sommes
là nous pour les aider et les orienter
et les aiguilles et si besoin mais le
site face on prend vraiment toute sa
splendeur et sa valeur lorsque lorsqu'il
est habillé pour de nombreux événements
oui
ce qui est important si on veut que
l'événement soit réussie il faut que les
lycées l'expérience des spectateurs par
yves 2024 va de mettre l'accent c'est un
sur le côté le côté expérience
spectateurs que ce soit de la prise de
on va dire de tickets l'achat du kit et
jusqu'à ce qu'ils arrivent sur site qui
vit pleinement l'événement et qui
repartent en disant waouh comme on a pu
le voir une loi ou pendant pendant cette
ryder cup avec pour les géo une jauge
adapter la jauge tournerait autour de
autour d'eux un petit peu plus de 30000
spectateurs jour ce qui est bien parce
que globale non mais quand on parle de
jeux olympiques mais y'a les messieurs
et les dames également est-ce que génial
ce qui veut dire qu'en fait on va avoir
deux semaines d'événements cirque on va
avoir huit jours de tournoi plus les
journées d'entraînement ce qui veut dire
qu'on va pendant quinze jours ici est
immergé dans une ambiance sport golf de
haut niveau seule question maintenant
qu'elle largeur pour les fairways quelle
vitesse pour le green
quelle fermeté et quid du parcours
jouables un peu moins ou difficile tous
ces ajustements devraient être décidées
trois à six mois avant l'événement
[Musique]
autre site
autre épreuve 7 du vtt qui se déroulera
ici même sur la colline d'élan pour une
colline transformée pour l'occasion et
pérenniser pour l'après jo ont fait le
point avec un spécialiste
thierry fabre organise une course de vtt
la revancharde
depuis 26 ans sur la colline d'elancourt
mais aussi des championnats de france et
des championnats d'europe
au total 70 compétition ont eu lieu sur
ces pistes arboré ici les gigots ils
sont particulièrement attendus pour nous
c'est une récompense
c'est le fruit du travail qu'on a
mobilisé avec nos bénévoles depuis des
années en construisant tous les sentiers
tous les chemins en dépolluant en
jardinant etc pour permettre à nos
adhérents et aux autres promeneurs et
aux autres vététistes de venir découvrir
ce site
tu
deux sites fait 52 hectares on exploite
une grande partie tout ce qui est sur la
périphérie du circuit un peu à
l'intérieur mais il ya beaucoup de
partis qui sont encore inexploitées et
nous on n'a pas les moyens pour créer
une nouvelle section est le fait des
quais les jeux olympiques
eh bien on va pouvoir découvrir d'autres
sites et surtout avec un circuit
sécurisé un circuit sécurisé et pourquoi
pas bien oui on est sur les terres du vc
skyteam vous sert et on
on aimerait bien nous qui a des circuits
olympique s'appelle revancharde
[Musique]
ans
mais thierry fabre pense déjà à l'après
jo et à la pérennisation du site
ça sera la force d'après les jeux que
tout le monde puisse venir en sécurité
se promener et aussi pour les sportifs
de tous niveaux que ce soit des
professionnels est dite ou des amateurs
ou des randonneurs tout le monde doit
pouvoir se retrouver dans ce site qui
sera fantastique
du côté de l'hôtel d'agglomération on
est déjà dans les starting blocks pour
que tout soit prêt le jour j pour
préparer les jo de 2024 saint quentin en
yvelines
on s'active mais on a quand même une
chance extraordinaire tiens à rappeler
que la majorité de nos sites sont déjà
prêts là on a le plus de travail à faire
c'est pour la colline d'elancourt ou la
colline par contre est fait on n'a pas
besoin de la bâtir ya déjà une colline
mais on a l'ensemble des aménagements
pour accueillir les épreuves de vtt qui
sont à faire
[Musique]
on
et
une piste a déjà été étudiée elle a été
dessinée par un spécialiste qui est
d'ailleurs d'origine d'afrique du sud
qui est le grand maître j'allais dire de
la conception des pistes de vtt pour les
jeux olympiques et les épreuves
internationales donc cette piste elle
est tracée sur le papier il faut
maintenant la réaliser il ya tous les
équipements écologiques c'est à dire on
va supprimer toute une végétation
invasive qui n'apportent pas de bénéfice
à cette colline qui va être
intégralement remplacées par une
nouvelle végétation qui alors a été
pensé pour durer et respecté sur le site
l'ensemble des espèces présentes
[Musique]
dans les prochains mois les futurs
aménagements seront présentés lors de
réunions publiques ainsi que l'après
gilles legrand concept de paris 2024
dans l'ensemble de toute organisation
mais particulièrement à 50 ans nous
vîmes et dans les yvelines c'est que le
bénéfice soit également et surtout et
avant tout pour la population après les
épreuves
[Musique]
je ne
direction le vélodrome nationale en
extérieur auront lieu les épreuves de
bmx à l'intérieur le cyclisme sur piste
et le pentathlon moderne dans le cadre
des jeux paralympiques pour vivre le
sport pleinement et autrement la 5g et
déployé le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sert
aujourd'hui de zone test pour la 5g mais
c'est pas la 5g comme un moyen de
communication parce que peu importe la
5g ce qui compte c'est ce qu'on va en
faire
pourquoi pas sur des vélos avoir des
capteurs de caméras et des capteurs de
rythme cardiaque qui permettrait en
temps réel à chaque spectateur de
pouvoir voir pour chaque coureur où on
en est s'immerger dans la course
[Musique]
encore une fois nous sommes une terre
d'innovation saint quentin en yvelines
et nous souhaitons pouvoir être à la
pointe de la technologie et inventer et
à travers cette nouvelle expérience
donné également une autre dimension aux
épreuves paralympiques
notre rôle à nous va être justement de
faire en sorte que la population
s'intéresse aussi aux jeux paralympiques
c'est un vrai enjeu fondamental
autre innovation les navettes autonome
en fonction depuis mars 2021 les trois
navettes circulent sur un parcours d'un
kilomètre 6 et desservent la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines et la zone
d'activités du pas du lac à montigny le
bretonneux
les jo sont aussi l'occasion d'innover
dans le domaine de la sécurité
le commissariat du futur devrait sortir
de terre en 2024 à elancourt dans le
quartier des contrats drones
vidéosurveillance celui ci sera muni
d'équipements ultramodernes pour des
jeux olympiques en toute sécurité
autres enjeux fondamentaux la gestion
des visiteurs un point sur lequel saint
quentin en yvelines a déjà de
l'entraînement ici le groupe national c
est un amphithéâtre du golfe il a reçu
pour la ryder cup près de 50000
spectateurs par jour et on a su gérer à
la fois la queue des spectateurs sur le
parcours mais tout ce qui touche aux à
côtés où garer les véhicules comment
revenir des parkings principaux vers les
parkings secondaire on a su gérer les
flux de populations de manière très
importante pour nos différents
événements n'est pour un territoire un
événement comme les jeux olympiques
dépasse de loin le cadre sportif
comme tous les grands événements à saint
quentin en yvelines et ailleurs les
retombées sont de plusieurs ordres
il ya bien entendu une amende de
retomber extraordinaire d'image c'est
indéniable saint quentin en yvelines
sera vu dans le monde entier par plus de
4 milliards de téléspectateurs c'est
bien évidemment des éléments qui attire
les entreprises mais également ceux qui
vont y travailler
et en cela le sport dans un territoire
comme le nôtre est absolument
fondamentale et par conséquent nous
attirons des gens qui viendront y
travaillent et y habitent et qui
souhaiteront certainement bien investir
sassine retombé très importante autre
retombée économique ré thouars
accueillir pendant plusieurs semaines
cinquante mille personnes par jour à 50
ans et vit bien c'est des gens qui vont
consommez utiliser l'infrastructure de
dormir déjeuner et qui par conséquent
vont tout simplement dépenser de
l'argent au bénéfice des commerçants de
saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
tout ce qui est dépensé au panneau
commerçants c'est bon aussi bien entendu
pour notre activité économique pour un
euro investi par un territoire comme le
nôtre c'est 5 euros de retombées
[Musique]
il ya une retombée également très
importante celle du sport pur
c'est-à-dire que pour nous motiver tous
et uns et les autres à pratiquer du
sport bien-être santé
il faut des grands exemples il faut des
modèles les jeux olympiques et les
athlètes dans les différentes
compétitions qui auront lieu à saint
quentin en yvelines
ce sont des modèles qui pousse notre nom
des populations et nous mêmes à
pratiquer le sport
ce fut le cas le 23 juin dernier à l'e3
cette journée une journée dédiée aux
jeux olympiques durant laquelle 500
collégiens saint quentinois s'étaient
réunis au golf national sur place
ateliers et démonstrations pour toutes
et tous et la présence de modèles de
grands champions olympiques
[Musique]
un avant-goût pour 2024 on est fin prêt
on anticipe on prépare en excitée et
ravie de pouvoir accueillir cet
événement ici donc on a cette expérience
on sait faire on est même très souvent
force de proposition parce que on est
ancré dans le réel on connaît notre
territoire
on a déjà cette expérience donc no
stress simplement du sérieux du
professionnalisme et des équipes de 50
ans yves hinse affaire en attendant tous
les regards se tournent vers les jeux
olympiques de tokyo
[Musique]
ce qui m'a accès fini à très bientôt au
numéro spécial était ciao
[Musique]